The crown jewels are a collection of historic
and obscenely valuable relics closely associated
with the British monarchy.
For centuries these golden, jewel-encrusted
trinkets have been kept under the watchful
eye of burly guards in the Tower of London.
And to doubly deter thieves, historically
the punishment for attempting to steal them
was death… something Thomas Blood thumbed
his nose at when he waltzed right into the
Tower of London and tried to steal them in
1671.
A charismatic and likeable man who reportedly
had oodles of Irish charm and a razor sharp
wit, Blood was able to get close to the most
cherished symbols of the British monarch by
the oldest conman trick in the book- simply
befriending an individual who had full access
to them, the 77 year old Keeper of the Jewels,
Talbot Edwards.
Blood visited the Tower of London disguised
as a humble clergyman and buttered Edwards
up with compliments before instructing an
attractive female companion who was an actress
posing as his wife to feign a crippling stomach
ache.
Edwards being the gentlemanly sort, and having
his apartment just above the place where the
crown jewels were kept, immediately called
for his wife to tend to Blood’s companion,
which allowed the self-styled dashing rogue
to begin working his magic on the rest of
the Edwards’ clan, showering them with small
gifts in a faux display of gratitude for tending
to his wife.
Upon successfully integrating himself into
the Edwards family’s good graces, Blood
casually mentioned that he had a wealthy nephew
who was looking to marry, knowing full well
that Edwards had been looking for a sufficiently
well-off suitor for his daughter.
Edwards understandably jumped at the chance
to meet this mysterious nephew and arranged
for a meeting- a meeting that Blood just so
happened to come to with not only his nephew
(who was actually his son), but also three
other companions, Robert Perrot, Richard Halliwell,
and William Smith.
As for these, when the group arrived at the
Tower of London on morning of May 9, 1671,
Smith was selected to wait outside the gates
with the horses while the others proceeded
to the Edwards’ abode.
While the group waited for Edwards’ wife
to prepare food, Blood casually asked if Edwards
would take them to go see the famed Crown
Jewels.
It should be noted here that part of Edwards’
job was in fact to show people who paid a
fee the jewels, so this was nothing terribly
out of the ordinary.
Thus, happy to oblige his new clergyman friend,
the elderly Keeper of the Jewels, said yes
and led the men downstairs to the room where
the Crown Jewels were stored.
As soon as the door to the room was unlocked,
Blood dropped his facade and the group roughly
beat Edwards and then stabbed him in the stomach
for good measure.
Once Edwards was subdued and gagged, Halliwell
went to serve as a lookout while Blood, the
son of a prominent and relatively wealthy
blacksmith, grabbed the crown and, using a
previously concealed mallet, quickly hammered
it flat in order to make it easy to conceal.
While he was doing that, Perrot unceremoniously
shoved the Sovereign Orb, symbolising the
might of the British empire, into his pants….
While all this was happening, Blood’s son
attempted to cut the Royal Sceptre in two
as it was too big to similarly conceal otherwise,
even for the most boastful of men.
Unfortunately for them, Halliwell alerted
the three that Edwards’ son had arrived
home and was looking for his father.
From here, it would appear the three decided
to flee without the sceptre a mere moment
before Edward’s son arrived.
A newsletter clipping written later that day
by one Mr. Kirke, then stated,
Mr Edward’s son coming in and finding that
his father had been hurt ran after [them].
One of the villains shot at him but missed,
as were the guards but they kept up with them
and captured two near the Iron Gate, old Blood
who was disguised as a priest called Ailoffe
and one called Perrott.
Afterwards Blood’s son [was captured] when
he fell from his horse near Gravel Lane, he
was named Hunt and was the person who had
kidnapped the Duke of Ormonde.
They were brought to Whitehall and taken into
custody, the other two escaped.
(And just a side note here to wrap up the
Keeper of the Jewels’ tale, he survived
this ordeal, despite his old age, the beating,
and being stabbed in the stomach.
King Charles II would also give him a small
stipend in reparation for his injuries suffered
in service to the crown.)
Upon being arrested, Blood, a somewhat prominent
fellow already owing to his exploits during
the English Civil War (including afterwards
twice trying to kill the Duke of Ormonde,
James Butler, and supposedly even making an
attempt on the King’s life), among other
escapades, refused to speak to anyone but
King Charles II himself about the events surrounding
his attempted robbery.
Amazingly, the King agreed to meet with Blood,
who we should probably mention already had
a bounty of one thousand pounds on his head
owing to his previous exploits unconnected
to this particular robbery.
During the meeting, Blood used every ounce
of his charm to amuse and ingratiate the King
and the others present, including The Duke
of York and various members of the royal family….
It worked.
After reportedly thoroughly entertaining the
King with the daring tale of the robbery,
the stories of the many adventures Blood had
had over his life, and throwing in a bit of
flattery, including telling the King he once
almost murdered him while the King was bathing
in the Thames, but stopped short when he witnessed
the King’s majesty, the King gave him a
full pardon.
And not just for this crime, but also for
any crimes Blood had committed between May
29, 1660 and the then present day of the pardon
proclamation, August 1, 1671.
Blood’s son and other captured companion
were likewise let go.
The good outcome didn’t stop there for Blood.
You see, during the English Civil War, Blood
had for a time supported Charles I, but when
the King appeared as if he would lose, Blood
switched sides.
Thus, when Charles I was ousted, Blood was
given an estate and made, ironically, a Justice
of the Peace.
However, when Charles II took over, this estate
was taken from Blood.
What does this have to do with his present
circumstances?
Well, not satisfied with just pardoning Blood,
King Charles II decided that in reparation
for Blood’s previously taken lands, the
King would give him an estate that provided
an annual income of around £500.
While it’s difficult to accurately translate
this amount to modern pounds, very loosely
speaking today this would be about a million
pounds worth of labor, or around £70,000
pounds (about $95,000) by value of the goods
one could buy.
There are various hypothesis as to why the
King rewarded the rogue in this matter.
One such speculation is that the whole affair
had been arranged by the Duke of Buckingham
and that he may have pulled some strings to
get Blood and his companions off the hook
when they failed.
(Buckingham would ultimately be something
of a patron of Blood.)
Another is that the King himself was behind
the attempted theft as a way to raise funds
for himself.
Yet another, this one perhaps slightly more
plausible, is suggested by famed diarist John
Evelyn,
Some believed he became a spie of severall
parties, being well with the Sectaries and
Enthusiasts, and did his Majesties services
that way, which none alive could do so well
as he…
In other words, perhaps in Blood the King
saw an intelligent, educated, charming, and
well connected person (among both the nobility
and criminal sects) who didn’t mind getting
his hands a little dirty to achieve an end,
so decided to pardon him and put him on a
pension via the estate, with at that point
Blood functioning as something of a spy and
political operative for the King.
However, there is no hard evidence to support
any of these suppositions and it may well
really be that he and his little escapade,
including the dashing way Blood described
it, simply amused the King as was reported
in contemporary accounts of the affair.
In that case, apparently the old adage of
“Crime Doesn’t Pay” doesn’t apply
if the absolute ruler of wherever you live
happens to find the crime especially hilarious.
Whatever the motivation, when Blood would
later die in 1680, not only would his body
later be exhumed just to double check he hadn’t
faked his death, but his epitaph read:
Here lies the man who boldly hath run through
More villainies than England ever knew;
And ne’er to any friend he had was true.
Here let him then by all unpitied lie,
And let’s rejoice his time was come
to die.